هذه منطقة كان فيها قدر لا
بأس به من
المدفعية الصادرة والواردة على الطريق ، وهي
مدينة قاتلت
عليها القوات الروسية والأوكرانية لعدة أيام
في هذه الأماكن المفتوحة الشاسعة ،
ويبدو أن الروس ليسوا بعيدين.
هنا ، جون
هنا ، استمر في التدحرج ،
فترى ذلك هناك ، نحن نعانق الأرض
مرتين أخريين من جولات المدفعية
يواصل المصور جون توريجوي التدحرج بشكل صحيح ،
لذلك كان لدينا
جولتان قادمتان تستجيبان
للمدفعية التي كانت تطلق في
الاتجاهات الروسية ،
جاءت تلك القذائف جميلة  بالقرب منا لم
يصب أحد بجروح ، أخبر الضابط
المترجم فاليريا دوبروفسكا أننا بحاجة
للذهاب الآن
اذهب بعيدًا ،
اضربها ، أركض ، حسنًا ،
أعتقد أنها آمنة ،
آمل أن تكون السيارة بخير على ما
يرام جاهزة للتحرك
، فلنذهب
، ولذا فإننا نركض بدرع كامل للجسم من أجل
السيارات التي
لا تستطيع إحدى السيارات تحريكها مليئة
بشظايا
نفقدها نحن نفقد البنزين ولا يمكنني
أن أضيع وقتًا
رميها في الخلف
السائق إيغور ثياغنو رايزر ركز
على إيصالنا إلى بر الأمان.  r أيضًا ضرب ،
اذهب جيدًا ،
نحن الآن نحاول
الخروج من هذه المنطقة بأسرع ما يمكن ، وقد
دمرت سيارتنا الأخرى تمامًا
محشورة في هذه السيارة الصغيرة ، اقتربنا من
أرض أكثر أمانًا
وسنذهب إلى  غطي هذه القرية بقوة وبعد
ذلك سنأخذ استراحة
المنتج كريم حيدر يتفقد الأضرار التي
لحقت بالسيارة والجنود الذين تركناهم وراءنا
لا يزالون هناك
ويمكننا تركهم
لا يمكنهم